if we're here to like debate the merits
of saying that everyone is beautiful
you're on the wrong Channel only all
girls are beautiful Oh girls are
beautiful like obviously Oh guys no
they're not no they get to run the world
they don't get to be beautiful sorry
preach sent me a video and I couldn't
stop laughing when I saw it so let's pop
it in okay so we had the same reaction
let's talk about us and what happens
when we get played by the ugly dude you
know who is kind of unattractive and an
absolute nightmare
ed Sheeran Edie Sharon I'm gonna talk
about us when he opened for Taylor Swift
um he and all of her friends I mean and
her friends like Victoria's Secret model
friends and then you know what he did
after he them he goes to them I want you
to picture being like a Victoria's
Secret model
and getting ghosted by Edie
Sharon old Google I'm exchanger this is
what happens when we let our ego take
over and we're desperate and we're sad
and wordl oh you know what we are we're
easy prey if we think about a herd of
like animals in Africa who is the lion
gonna pick off not the biggest strongest
deer loping across the plain
not that antelope the weak ones the
stragglers wait you think Ed Sheeran was
able to bring those Victoria's Secret
models because they were feeling
insecure no he was able to know the
Victoria's Secret models because he was
Ed Sheeran that's it
do you know how many people want Ed
Sheeran even when he was opening for
Taylor Swift he'd won like numerous
awards by that point and he was named
Britain's top artists and women
the highlighted dudes cheesy
he's sippin that lemonade all day every
day emotionally in life that's what we
become and so we run headlong towards
the predator hey your words girl he did
use the right ones
she didn't predator she didn't you gonna
coin consensual with predator because
that put all that much didn't feel that
that's not the case you know what I hate
about this kind of surface it just makes
women sound like they have no agency no
they do and they're never liable for any
of the decisions that they make I know
plenty of women who stay at home and
would refuse to bang ed sheeran despite
him being famous because they don't want
to go for that like if you are a high
level woman and you go for that right if
you leverage your looks as a Victoria's
Secret model be with hit against his
fame why are you surprised when he
decides to pull out
it's interesting to me that men who
women at high levels are predators but
that women who use men at high levels
are not gold diggers and it's just
interesting to hear a woman constantly
define them as an ugly guy but men are
really superficial man or shallow okay
one of the biggest problems with ugly
boys is that when you start dating them
they start thinking there are ten and
get slick it's interesting
and this body positivity all women are
beautiful all bodies are beautiful for
some reason ugly men having confidence
is unacceptable but fat ugly women who
want to have confidence the best thing
ever it's empowering do you want to feel
loved back to life right you want to
like get your mojo back so you go for
the guy you dial down either your
standards so wait do you think that the
the Victoria's Secret models were dating
down when they got that shirt you mean a
guy who can literally have his pick of
the litter with pretty much most women
on this planet you felt like they were
dating down and they lowered their
standards
really but like empirically there are
some people who are more I don't know
beauties and I have it all whatever if
we're here to like debate the merits of
saying that everyone is beautiful you're
on the wrong channel only all girls are
beautiful all girls are beautiful like
obviously Oh guys no they're not no they
get to run the world they don't get to
be beautiful sorry
go on say it brother I'm legit
speechless was just happen oh that's the
first I feel like she owned herself
she's like empirically some people are
more beautiful than either sounds like
okay I'm with you but all women are
beautiful not men because my feelings
knowing I can't argue with something
that's incomprehensible how do I undo
logic that that's not even logical in
its own sentence cuz I need saying and
after you again said I can't I can't
argue against fair you know maybe she's
joking so I'm just gonna give her the
benefit of the doubt but some I'm being
very generous this girl is so dumb I
haven't even noticed her tits and then
ghost and then he necks you he needs you
and you flip out the guys have been like
the most twisted over have been
situations like this and finally one day
I woke up I'm like it's not my heart
that's broken it's my ego gonna happen
is that when everybody get rejected from
ugly guys the way a girl like that's
gonna think is that I'm doing good and
I'm also giving a chance to another guy
because I'm this standard I'm alone in
my standards ie dating down I am free
you know her it's like if you walking
down the street and you see a homeless
person and you're like young blessing do
you want a sandwich and the homeless
person is like No thank you I'm vegan
which they don't want a sandwich
but because you look down and you gave
the sandwich and you may reject it
I'm a rejected by all this you don't
even eat all day rejected me and girl an
ego takes a lot longer to heal than a
heart it depends how big we deal is and
depends I'll not exist in your hardest
if a heartbreak is a lot easier to get
over you than a ego bruised booboo you
might be a sociopath
infinitely an ego bruised like goes on
forever because you can't it's like a
logic trap you're like I can't compute
I'm seven I'm a point but I can't like
in so you just get caught caught caught
caught caught in this loop because it's
never gonna make sense like what why is
I just listen it I thought you left me
on rent you left me I don't know maybe
it's because I'm socialized as a man but
you're used to taking else you take l's
not just from women but from life from
people who are worse and stronger than
you
I thought meet up by somebody who's
smaller than me when I was seven I'd
never forget that I was supposed to win
that fight brother I got [ __ ] in the
stomach and you know that you know that
[ __ ] in front of my whole Brit my family
my brother and we've walked back to walk
ashamed but that was a humbling
experience for me I've had to take else
like that my whole life you know what
they say about else I'm saying two
wrongs don't make a right but two else
make a w and so I'm first of all we end
up feeling worse than when we started
right like we feel infinitely more
worthless kinda because we were barking
up the wrong tree right kind of because
we were objectifying someone and China
every time he says China I hear China
China because we were people China
because we have the coronavirus sign now
because we got a lot of Asians and the
guys who have done this to me the ugly
guys have done this to me they were
famous all of them every single one of
them was famous and what I have talked
to them if they weren't nope
you just you just you suggested your
ownself exactly the point so at the
beginning of the video you can't be like
oh this is something that happens to me
when you just said hey Chyna
no no no talking about all this thing is
happening to me and then I'd add to what
I was talking to him if he wasn't that
exactly you obey the phone back over
here let's go just know you're not in
the pudding you're not you're not in the
perfect state of mind a song just give
it time
and give it a thing I read something
press pause I always see insurance face
like I [ __ ] them [ __ ] what I see
every time I press pause but here's the
problem with like people who grew up
unpopular or feeling like they were ugly
or whatever they have something called
kill the cheerleader syndrome that's
what I call it we're like they are so
fixated on their past and how they were
like mistreated and nobody liked them
when they were 13 I've got news for you
guys
no one likes anyone when they're 13 so
it bothers me when guys have this like
wounded victim mentality bus so you're
gonna say man half victim mentality when
you say the reason why the early guy is
going to OD though the good-looking
girls good-looking guy was really mad
and something happened there and you
know we've got the president we want to
be heard but we're the ones with victim
mentality oh not only you talk dumb you
don't even understand it something that
you say they have admit victim mentality
but all you've been able to describe was
a victim mentality
listen probably guys who have high value
we have to stop defining them as ugly
men and sure it is not ugly man ed
sheeran is a desirable man because he's
got money right you can't define someone
by an attribute that doesn't have that
much impact on how endearing they are do
you understand what I'm saying meaning
if I'm thinking of buying a company all
right I'm not going to define that
company or buy the shoes that the
employees wear because that's not what
they're selling point is they're selling
point is their commercial value
so you see it as a profitable company
when I look at it shoot I don't think
ugly man I think of a hyper successful
artist who has done world tours and is
desired because of his skill set that's
how you define him so when you define a
that's just an ugly man or as an ugly
man you're disregarding what makes him
endearing to other people one two guys
who are less attractive and who grew up
less physically attractive and not as
attractive to women when they were
younger don't get old or older become
attractive and then reject hot women
because they're angry about their
childhood they reject you ladies who are
very attractive because you don't have
much to offer other than your looks
because you ain't got nothing exactly he
might be hot but he has no ambitions and
nothing else you would probably reject
them so when you come to the negotiating
table for example and you're just a hot
woman with very little else to offer me
right after I've slept with you I've
already consumed your beauty think of it
as a negotiating process right you're
leveraging your and your looks versus my
charm and my status right
once I've slept with you which is what I
wanted out of the negotiation process
and once you've wasted my time which is
what you wanted at the negotiation
process my attention all this stuff what
comes after I've already had what else
do you bring to the table nothing and so
why would I stay at the negotiating
table and try to offer what someone's
something that they can't offer me in
return the reality is ladies after your
looks there has to be something else for
me to invest in getting a guy is easy
making him stays a lot of women's
problems if you think that we're running
away or leaving you or ghosting you
because we want to get revenge then you
really don't understand us sometimes we
just like the peace and quiet of your
absence when I've gone for the other guy
famous or not it's like I feel like I
need to be adored more so I'm gonna go
for a guy who I have evaluated is not as
good as me and he needs he needs to be
my fan right that's kind of twisted and
messed up isn't it impressive how she
thinks her looks
makes her equal to an ugly person who's
famous what she was given to her
genetically she thinks makes her equal
to someone who's worked hard and had to
persevere through so much in order to
get to his point in life it's impressed
the arrogance of women who have so
little to offer yet they think they
deserve so much is impressive but I
digress only women get to be beautiful
here's some of the comments because this
is not an isolated thing her friends
love this video
why hot girls choose ugly plain-jane
boys in my case I thought they were
harmless and easy to get along okay so
you had insecurities and you thought
that just because I looked a little bit
less hot than that yeah what I'm gonna
because I'm less attractive I have to
have a more docile personality super
complex if you go to a stripper join you
look good
curls are not gonna go to you
necessarily because they're gonna think
you don't need them Wow
she's like I'm not gonna go for that guy
right like yeah I could go with that
knocking because yeah ugly guys have
just way too much nerve especially if
they're rich never trust a rich ugly guy
ladies are salty because dudes are
realizing that they don't have to wife
up these useless brats in order to get
what they want and now you mad cuz
people don't see your value actually
really fries now you mad because people
see your real value and so if you're mad
because your value isn't being
recognized it's probably because your
product isn't that valuable it's like
running a business if people are buying
your product once and they're not return
customers that's because your product
wasn't that good you might have a good
packaging but if the if the product is
garbage you're not buying again it might
look good and everything but if it
tastes bad and you know I beli that
kitchen was nice but the product was
doing there you go if I don't leave a
good review it's because the product
wasn't good if your standards are really
high and you can't find a man it's
probably cuz you're over valuing the
products I'm drawing a parallel to
business just so you guys can understand
but a lot of people are unreasonable
it's why when I see ugly guys with
extreme standards when I want a
Victoria's Secret model like [ __ ] you
ain't got [ __ ] to offer you live in your
mom's basement ain't you ugly it's not
gonna happen
lower your standards or ditch your
skills up one or the other
that's how cutthroat it is for men but
for ladies not ugly guys are just being
unreasonable
you suck it's your fault learn to take
else and turn them into double use
anything else one add
cool thank you showing me
[Music]